[تصفيق]
سباق الوصول الى البيت الابيض يتحرك من
موازاته سباق قضائي يجادل البعض بامكانيه
تاثيره على فرص ترشح ترامب لخوض
الانتخابات الرئاسيه
سعي ترامب للعوده الى كرسي الرئاسه في عام
ترافقه اتهامات عده تهدف للنيل من رصيده
من الاصوات لمنعه من الفوز بتمثيل
الجمهوريين في الانتخابات المقبله بحسب
مراقبين اخرها على المستوى الفيدرالي
وتشمل عرقله العداله وسوء التعامل مع
وثائق البيت الابيض السريه والكذب بشانها
تحقيقات اخرى تطال ترامب اولها قضيه
الهجوم على الكابيتول واتهامه بتحريض
انصاره بعد فوز جو بايدن في انتخابات 2020
كما دخلت على سلسله الاتهامات مواصله
التحقيق بمحاوله ترامب قلب نتائج انتخابات
جورجيا لصالحه في عام 2020 قضايا ماليه في
نيويورك اتهم بها ترامب الاحتيال المالي
والضريبي ايضا الى جانب قضيه الممثله
الاباحيه
التي اتهمت ترامب شراء صمتها بشان علاقه
خارج الزواج تعود الى عام
الهجمات القانونيه قد تعكر صفو حملات
ترامب الانتخابيه لكنها لن تعيق ترشحه اذ
ان القرارات والاحكام القانونيه بشان
القضايا المتهم بها قد تتاخر بالصدور الى
ما بعد الانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله وربما
يحصل حينها على الحصانه اذا ما فاز اما
فكره استبعاد ترامب كمرشح رئاسي فتنبع من
عدم ذكر الماده اثنين من الدستور الامريكي
التي تحدد مؤهلات الرئاسه لاي شيء عن
الاتهامات او الادانات الجنائيه انتقال
الجمهوري وتاييد ديمقراطي تباينت
التعليقات من داخل الكونجس فالجمهوريون
وصفوا الاتهامات بالمسيسه بينما اعتبرها
الديمقراطيون تاكيدا على سياده القانون
اياد حمود العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد
من البرامج
والوثائقيه وتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات